[Musica]
mi chiamo paola barbato e sono una
sceneggiatrice di fumetti è una
scrittrice di romanzi thriller negli
incontri che faccio col pubblico e ne
faccio parecchi mi viene spesso posta
questa domanda da dove nasce un
personaggio come fai a sviluppare un
personaggio partendo dal nulla
beh ogni personaggio viene mosso da
qualcosa questo qualcosa possiamo
definirlo come un nucleo emotivo
facciamo un esempio immediato pratico
devo sviluppare un serial killer
cos'è che può spingere un serial killer
un'insoddisfazione un senso di
ingiustizia è convinto che gli sia stato
fatto un torto è convinto che sia stato
trattato male è convinto di meritare di
più benissimo mi guardo intorno nel
mondo nell'esistenza che attraverso
normalmente dove vado a trovare questi
sentimenti a una fila imposta
voi andate lì e trovate persone che
pensano che quelli al di là dello
sportello li stiano facendo aspettare
troppo
che siano ingiusti che non debbano
pagare quello che stanno per pagare che
quello di fianco gli e passato davanti
c'è questa insoddisfazione e quel nucleo
emotivo si può tranquillamente centrare
prendere allungare un po come un
bastoncino e quindi far muovere girare e
raccogliere tutte quelle sensazioni e
quelle emozioni che appartengono a me o
che appartengono le persone che sono
intorno a me e che sono analoghe a quel
nucleo motivo lo fili lo figli un po
come come si fa dello zucchero filato no
cioè lo gonfi lo rende sempre più ampio
sempre il compito complesso sempre più
completo finché l'ha vinta una specie di
bozzolo chiamiamolo così a quel punto la
maggior parte dei colleghi definisce ciò
che deve avvenire al personaggio un
conflitto
io preferisco usare il termine trauma
tutti i personaggi attraversano un
trauma questo trauma cos'è il trauma può
essere un evento qualunque che divide la
vita in prima e dopo
può essere anche un evento positivo non
è detto che debba essere negativo nella
vita della maggior parte delle persone
non certo punto arriva un figlio e il
figlio divide la vita in prima e dopo
una vincita di denaro un avanzamento
lavorativo sono tutti traumi sono delle
condizioni che ci obbligano ad
abbandonare quello che eravamo e
diventare un altra cosa è la base di
ogni evoluzione qualsiasi qualsiasi
nuovo raggiungimento scientifico per
esempio uccide quello precedente
qualsiasi nuova concezione filosofica
uccide quella precedente
ogni evoluzione nasce dalla morte di ciò
che c'era prima e lo stesso vale per noi
noi diventiamo qualcosa e abbandoniamo
quello che eravamo prima
non necessariamente è un evento positivo
ci sono degli elementi negativi che sono
classici la morte il lutto il lutto di
qualcuno è un elemento che cambia cambia
l'esistenza delle persone la malattia
la marvel tirare il più grande
spartiacque di tutti perché sulla carta
siamo bravi siamo coraggiosi siamo
generosi ma quando arriva la malattia
improvvisamente la nostra vera natura
emerge qualche volta non è quella che ci
aspettavamo
poi c'è l'elemento più classico che il
fallimento che cosa avviene a questo
punto la metafora più classica qual è la
larva la farfalla il bozzolo la
crisalide la crisalide è il trauma
nel momento in cui uno cambia abbandona
la crisalide che resta lì resta una
sfoglia vuota una specie di simbolo di
ciò che eravamo io preferisco usare il
termine carapace mi piace di più pensare
che abbandoniamo un guscio perché perché
quando ci evolviamo diventiamo una cosa
nuova e questa cosa nuova non può essere
protetta come si si proteggeva prima ma
deve trovare una nuova protezione questa
nuova protezione non può nascere se noi
non sappiamo dove possiamo essere
colpiti se non sappiamo di cosa abbiamo
paura
se non siamo in qualche maniera
sguarniti nella simbologia fumettistica
ma anche in quella letteraria di solito
questo passaggio viene rappresentato
come la caduta e il risollevamento che
danno origine quasi sempre all'errore
l'eroe nasce così l'eroe cade e trova la
forza di rialzarsi
io ho affrontato esattamente questo
passaggio con un personaggio a fumetti
molto noto in italia che si chiama dylan
dog dylan dog è un investigatore del
soprannaturale si chiama indagatore
dell'incubo de nato dalla penna dalla
mente straordinaria di tiziano sclavi
bene dylan dog ha vissuto questo prima e
questo dopo era un poliziotto un bravo
poliziotto un bravo ragazzo integerrimo
pieno di dubbi pieno di fragilità
grondante di fragilità ma molto
spalancato verso l'esterno pieno di
speranze nei confronti del mondo
poche certezze su di sé ma grandi
speranze nei confronti del mondo di
l'anno attraverso un trauma sua moglie
muore nel momento in cui muore la moglie
di dylan in qualche maniera si crepa
proprio questa speranza che lui aveva
per il mondo la sofferenza del
personaggio è tale che lui inizia a
perdere tutto al di là dell'amore cioè
perde l'amore ma poi per il suo
comportamento inadeguato perde il lavoro
per della salute diventa un alcolista
perde gli affetti per che respinge tutte
le persone che ha intorno perde
praticamente ogni elemento che prima era
presente nella sua vita e resta da solo
è una solitudine totale perché di lana
nulla ogni aspetto della sua persona in
favore del dolore dylan diventa dolore è
talmente privo di qualsiasi altra
emozione che è incapace di badare a se
stesso anche per le cose fondamentali
l'immagine iconica di questa sua caduta
il momento più basso e più drammatico è
quando di l'anno a un certo punto non è
neanche più in grado di cambiarsi
d'abito ma riesce soltanto ogni sera a
mettere i suoi vestiti in lavatrice air
indossarli il giorno dopo a questo punto
che cosa avviene qual è qual è il
passaggio da dal personaggio caduto
all'eroe e quando dylan capisce che
effettivamente l'unica cosa che lui può
fare è continuare a guardare fuori forse
non con speranza perché questa speranza
non ce l'ha ma sicuramente il suo dolore
o che implodere e quindi a un'unica
speranza che è fuori di sé
decide quindi di cominciare a salvare
ciò che al di fuori di lui
la prima persona che salva è un tizio
senza nome un senzatetto che accoglie in
casa sua e diventerà il suo assistente e
co protagonista che è il sosia di
groucho marx il secondo salvataggio di
dylan dog è quello di una vecchia
macchina che ha destinato allo
sfasciacarrozze che diventerà il suo
fedele maggiolone che è diventato
iconico al punto da non poter essere
rappresenti ha rappresentato in altri
fumetti il terzo salvataggio che dylan
opera è quello nei confronti né il suo
vecchio capo quindi dell'ispettore bloch
che vive una vita terribile perché e
padre di un figlio tossicodipendente che
ha un destino già segnato
dylan si proietta al di fuori di sé
comincia a trovare la propria salvezza
nella salvezza degli altri
comincia a capire che il suo dolore può
essere una spinta è un modo propulsivo e
quindi il pubblico che lo segue e che
vede che lui è fatto di questo di dubbio
di fragilità non assomiglia minimamente
all'eroe classico fra dylan e superman
superman e su un piedistallo dylan dog e
qui è un passo da te è fatto come te ha
paura come te
soffre come te è incapace di sapere se
sia nel giusto o nello sbagliato magis
agisce questo per il lettore è
fondamentale perché si identifica perché
se di line può salvare il mondo una
persona alla volta
un gesto alla volta una speranza alla
volta un mostro alla volta perché dylan
cerca di salvare anche ciò che non
capisce allora anche il lettore può
farlo e si rende conto che anche il suo
dolore anche la sua fragilità anche la
sua tristezza può essere un modo
propulsivo per diventare qualcosa di
meglio qualcosa di più grande e quindi
come dylan abbandona il suo carapace che
è fatto di dolore anche il lettore può
abbandonare un passo alla volta il
proprio carapace ma senza guardarlo con
disprezzo perché in fondo quel carapace
quella crisalide è esattamente la base
da cui potrà spiccare il salto e
diventare qualcos'altro
[Applauso]
grazie